the pro football hall of famer whose
speech at the hall of fame is just
fantastic
and um he is going to be the subject of
this week's
football life on nfl network tomorrow
night
at nine eastern time the great the one
and only megatron himself calvin johnson
here on the rich eisen show how are you
calvin johnson
i'm doing great how you doing rich
thanks for having me uh your speech was
incredible in canton it was great oh wow
thank you very much i can't i can't
watch it but i did get a real feedback
what do you mean why why won't you you
you just don't i hate hearing myself
talk i keep listening to myself so are
you going to say you're not going to
watch back this interview here on the
rich either show calvin once
it's done it's done
[Laughter]
have you watched your football life
though have you watched that yet
i have not i have the clip but i have
not watched wow what is that
i want to watch it though because i have
teammates on their coaches on there you
know i love this hero they have i love
to hear what they have to say sometimes
it's pretty good okay will you watch it
though or you're just gonna not at all
you're just you'll see i'll watch it i
gotta watch it my watching let me watch
it yeah
okay did you want to watch it i really
do i think i think the crew that put it
together i had a good experience with
those guys too so
yeah i'm looking forward to him nobody's
better than nfl films and nfl network
together calvin johnson i mean this is
great i mean i'm i'm looking forward to
seeing it that is that is for sure
um let's talk a little bit of the here
and now and then we'll we'll go back in
the past if you don't mind um you're
what what what was your experience like
this week getting your hall of fame ring
um
at the lions ravens game calvin awesome
i mean it's better than i thought you
know just stepping down on that field
feeling the energy you know like they go
through my toes all the way up to my
head you know uh from the fans you know
they brought it you know it was loud i
mean i haven't been too many games the
only thing that's probably my second
time back in that stadium since i
retired and uh that they brought the
energy the same energy that i felt when
i played on sundays you know they
brought it but i i was truly grateful to
be up there the honor to go back in
and and be in front of the fans again
when you said it went from your head to
your toes what do you mean by that what
do you mean they enter just the energy
the noise you know just your hair
raising you know it's just that that
that just that just that feeling just
running through your veins just that
energy okay and you ran away probably
it's probably just adrenaline
well i mean what is it that's it now you
got the bus the jacket and you got the
last bauble now you got the ring
um and you are you've got it all you're
officially in what does that mean for
you calvin johnson that you are
enshrined and is a first ballot hall of
famer and one of the youngest to ever be
as such
how does that land on you right now
calvin
it's wild you know just i i take it here
i just think about the guys that i
looked up to that were in that room when
they're ready to lunch and then the guys
the guys that i looked up to who they
looked up to that were in that same room
and there might have been even another
generation just to see the levels of
excellence and greatness and how it's
just you know passed on down because
we're always looking to the prior
generation to you know just to emulate
our game after those guys to you know
just to try to create our own
our own stamp and uh you know just to be
there uh it was breathtaking it was on
i'm a kid in the candy shop literally
the whole weekend i couldn't even say a
word i'm just looking around like oh
shoot that's something that's something
oh that's second question you know just
having a conversation
um with my class you know from charles
to peyton to coach flores to
to uh
or even the 2020 class
you know even drew p you know just great
times you know good people
and just to represent excellence and all
that the game stands for just be a part
of that representation is a heck of an
honor and now that you are you you've
got all that personal accolades and the
ultimate personal accolade you could
possibly get first ballot pro football
hall of famer and you got the ring in
front of the home fans are are you
cooler now or are better uh standing
with the lions you and the lions closer
together at all or
or
not at all calvin johnson i mean we we
came close on sunday you know you know i
mean as far as you know just getting
back together you know there's still
some work to be done there you know but
hopefully that can happen you know
hopefully it'll happen because you know
the fans you see the fans want it
so is that in reference to scratching a
check
calvin
i didn't say that but yeah i mean that's
that's i mean that's really what it
takes to restore well i don't look i i
and and you know just to linger just for
a couple more minutes here i i
well i i i just still i'm scratching my
head so when you retired and obviously
it was sooner than the organization
thought
did they just say give us our money give
us some money back i mean like there
wasn't even a conversation at all or
because so many other players retire
early and their organizations just say
keep it thanks for the memories they
never did that
with you
no i mean they might have had
conversations i can't say what they have
on my agent but not me personally
okay so all right so um
is there a possibility of the this
relationship getting closer then i guess
i'm not gonna burn the bridge because i
mean i think that you know the the team
or the executives you know it's all how
much the fans enjoy you know me being
around the team i enjoy being around the
team i also i mean i still live in
detroit because you know not only
because of the love that detroit gives
me business opportunities too but i love
detroit because of the people calvin
johnson pro football hall of famer here
on the rich eisen show mercedes-benz
vans
phone line in advance of the football
life on nfl network friday night at nine
eastern time best wide receiver in the
nfl right now
would be who in your estimation
man i hate when you when you give me
that question because i i'm i'll say i'm
not on i'm not up to speed on everything
i still watch football but i'm not you
know uh i always forget something i
always give it like a guy dimension or
something like that the best wide
receiver in
oh do i do some research yeah
you can get back to us no i mean you
know obviously there's i have guys that
i love b-hop you know i think i like
b-hop he's been my favorite for a little
while just because he used the way he
used his hands
you know he runs a good route he seems
like a hard worker he uses his hands
he seems like a respectable um human
being you know just and i respect stuff
like that you know and people that carry
themselves well but at the same time go
out there and handle their business on
the field he he wound up in the top 10
of the top 100 players uh as voted by
his peers on the nfl network but the the
the receiver who was ranked higher than
him was devonte adams he was viewed by
his peers in terms of the voting of this
as the best receiver in the game
i always forget somebody i mean
i saw devante from when he was a rookie
in green bay and to see his growth and
maturity you know i i can't forget that
i mean i'd be a slightly forget about
him too because he's grown a lot to
become know like say that that that top
receiver in the league so uh he's
definitely uh got control of that that
number one spot over there in green bay
well perhaps uh since you say you're
you're not as you know uh day to day
with watching the nfl or week to week
watching the nfl are you aware that they
have changed the rule that if somebody
catches a ball and puts the ball down on
the ground to avoid uh going to the
ground that that is now a catch it is no
longer an incomplete pass are you aware
that the calvin johnson rule has been
changed calvin johnson well why why why
why i feel like every year like they
tweak it every year a little bit you
know so that is crazy really yeah that
was ridiculous that was ridiculous that
your
touchdown pass of back in the day was
ruled incomplete because you put the
ball on the ground to avoid going to the
ground kind of makes a ridiculous
concept
it's absurd you know i mean that don't
bring back bad feelings about the first
game of the season we were ready for
that game and you know it
brings back all kind of bad news well
then let's talk good good stuff then
what do you think of uh the start of
matthew stafford here in los angeles and
what he has been able to do in just his
first three games in a new spot calvin
johnson i'll tell you whatever i tell
everybody else man uh i got i got
opportunity obviously to play with matt
for so long he has the biggest arm in
the league he'll put the ball on anybody
anywhere it seems like he's still got it
and
you know i watch the game the first game
of their season and there's a moment in
the game where they they cut to matthew
after like some play i don't remember
what happened it might have been a
penalty or something like that and
you saw matthew's face almost like
oh it wouldn't happen like that in
detroit okay i might have something here
you almost sent that that's coming out
of him and just in that look i got i
know matthew a little bit i'm just like
oh shoot that's what it would have went
down like that in detroit you know
so kudos to matthew he got a great team
great coach and i look forward i mean
right now he's like you know a lot of
people's favorites to be in the food
bowl so
how difficult do you think it was for
him because the reporting is and we've
i've spoken to him as well to confirm it
how difficult it was for him to go into
the front office of the lions and say i
want out
but i want to keep playing
um how tough do you think that was for
him
calvin uh
i can imagine you know there's a lot of
emotions tied to detroit like that the
people have have a hold on you you know
he's looking for his whole entire
professional life you know so i can
understand how it can be tough but at
the same time when when when the
organization isn't building towards
super bowl you know you're you know
maybe you know at the peak or going on
the other side of your career you know
you're trying to get there and matthew
still has the tool to get there so he
got he got he got to do what's best for
him and you never thought about doing
that yourself you just wanted to stop
playing
calvin i mean when i was done i feel
like i couldn't keep from the same
product on the field so i knew that
whenever that time came that that i'll
be be done and i mean even my agent i
even tried to get me to come back you
know but it was he's like well what if
what if they trade you here but you know
they weren't trading me anywhere so i
was stuck in detroit where would you
have wanted to go
how about that um you know just just and
this is just you know just so everybody
knows this is just wishful thinking you
know
um but no i mean i played my obviously
i'm from georgia played my college ball
there it was cool to you know take it
full circle and just do um you know high
school college and professional all in
one town that would be cool then go to
the falcons at that point in time matt
ryan
you're saying okay i would have you know
i've been awesome to play it all at home
you know that was just the best case
scenario
well you know my guy from uh new england
over there was ready to chime in in my
ear and say you know dude patriots like
i thought you wanted to play with tom
calvin
i know you know what you know uh that's
that's tough tom's great you know
i mean there's nothing to argue there
yeah he doesn't play in georgia though
that's this is his point before i let
you go i want to give you uh some of the
floor here calvin about what you talked
about in
your pro football hall of fame speech
that you're the founder of your own
marijuana business called primitive and
how um how you want to make sure that
that marijuana use not just medically
but holistically is something that the
league should allow and all of us in the
world should understand is not something
that should be frowned upon or made to
be illegal i'll give you the floor on
that calvin yeah yeah thank you um i
mean you just think about it the way you
know people have healed for thousands of
thousands of years before technology got
into play with plant medicine in general
so you know having these plants here and
the technology that we have now nowadays
there's no reason why we can't have the
best but you know being a schedule one
drug you can't research it we have very
little knowledge on cannabis right now
but there are research efforts by like
people like you know harvard medical
school the university of penn and so
many others that are actually doing it
nowadays but for a lot of people it's
really just educating themselves and the
first i would say the first thing is and
that's what our company is about is
about educating removing the stigma from
from the plant and just educating people
on the healing powers of the plant and i
say the first place to start for people
is really just to think and do your
research for yourself on the
endocannabinoid system
we have this system within our bodies
that accepts cannabinoids but not a lot
of people know about all the receptors
that our body has for this though it's
like it's literally like it's made for
us but we have to obviously use it in
the proper way for to have a chilling
property you know we're not a company
just out here celebrating you know or
don't use or or you know like my buddy
rob and co founder you know we're not
the company with the gorilla with the
bluntness mouth no we're about education
education investing the plant so you
know really just educating people and
i'll tell people to start their life
educate yourself on your endocannabinoid
system and then go from there i
guarantee if you learn that your body
has a system that you don't even know
about that you might want to look more a
little bit more into it so how did it
help you uh recover after games and
stuff like that for sure how did it help
my journey like i started um in college
because i mean i grew up my mom was like
you know my mom probably slapped me
inside the head if i came home no she
was stupid more than that she body
slammed me like i came home fell on
camera so it was just automatic no no
for me growing up right when i got
college you know you came a little you
know tried it and you know socially
through college it was really when i got
to the nfl where i really started to
deal with the games and the pain and i
was like man this is something that
really helps me with my sleep this is
what helps i mean and the effort that
helps me with my recovery but it wasn't
until after i retired and did the
dancing with the stars show
when i was doing the show my ankles were
swelling up like in the second or third
week and i couldn't get it back down i
did my ice and game ready and all those
things but i had a buddy from georgia
tech and he brought me a topic because
i'm about to quit the show and he
brought me this top week i tried this
out you know and i started using the top
cool over the course of the week you
know i noticed that my
my swelling started to subside and that
was part of my reason when i was playing
football i had chronic swelling in my
ankle so i was like man i can't move
because i got swell it so i noticing
that start to subside i'm like okay
there's other applications to these
cannabinoids to the body okay let's get
down to the science of it and really
just timing having an opportunity here
in michigan to be able to build a brand
um focused around education and cannabis
and and obviously make a business out of
it that's what we're gonna know were you
ever concerned about testing positive
for you know
substances in the nfl because it was
viewed differently when you were playing
was ever a concern i mean yeah i mean
but guys know the don't know the system
i mean for the most part
you know what you know what's so messed
up about the system right now
do you know the significance of 420
please tell yes
say that again
do you know the significance of 420 yes
april april the 20th is a terrific date
on the calendar calvin
so how about this
say shame on you
but how about this so
420 but the first april 20 was the first
day of the testing so between 4 20 and
august like 8th or 9th that's like the
window where they test so it was just
like evil upon the nfl just
just playing but it was evil for them to
start it on 420.
calvin johnson uh we need to talk more
often again your speech was tremendous
it was just terrific i couldn't have
been more happy for you and your family
and
to see you now in the hall of fame and
your bust and you know uh
and
it's just great i mean it was the
greatest all hair bust team in the
history of busts and you know and you
and your bus was perfect too man so
congratulations on all of that the
football life and i just i know what i'm
going to do after football life is i'm
going to watch this interview back
because that's what i do professionally
is watching myself
rich man it's been a long time i think
the last time i saw you was when i was
up there when you and stuart scott were
really doing your thing man so it's been
a long time
that is so cool you mentioned him calvin
because i i think of him all the time
and what he would say about what goes on
in sports and in the world and what he
would be thinking about everything
that's going on in the nfl and obviously
the nba and
i appreciate oh god last last one for
you did you give your shoes to somebody
to run it at the combine or did somebody
give you what's
somebody gave you a heads up about it
from the nfl films no which i imagine
that's going to be in tonight's football
life but but i mean friday's football
life what what happened with those shoes
did you
so there was i forget the last
quarterback that was running the 40 um
they're right before the receivers that
day and for somebody for some reason he
showed up to the the most important job
interview of his life without this creep
so
he i gave him my cleats he fortunately
had the worst outside team he was
literally the last person to run it was
because it was meant to be so he ran and
everybody saw him giving me back my
cleat
right before it was time for me to go
run and then the dude that was like
marshalling everybody over there running
40 you probably know who he is running
every year um
he um he was yelling at me because i was
laughing into the group so everybody
just saw that that that that transaction
happened there and they said oh you
rented somebody else's creed so you ran
in your shoes at the combine is what
you're saying and actually you know even
let's go back before that i actually
showed up to the combine without any
clicks because i wasn't going to do
anything right but all these a lot of
reporters kept on talking talking all
this [ __ ] i'm not going to run and i was
like okay
all right all right i've been working
down here with tom shaw all summer i
know i know what i'm running let me go
show y'all at 240.
and what'd you run again in your 40
435.
that is a stupid number that is a stupid
number
um and so who was the quarterback who
you gave the cleats to do you remember
that or you don't remember that oh i
feel yeah i know i know i mean i think i
need to go maybe
eastern carolina
oh
yeah it was gerard was it david gerard
is that who that was
i think it might have been so
definitely you did not whoever it was
definitely didn't run a 435 in the shoes
it's not the shoes it was the guy in the
shoes
calvin you take care of yourself you be
well okay
youtubers
the one and only pro football hall of
famer calvin johnson check out his
football life tomorrow night nfl network
9 eastern time
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here